all right radio audiences away first of
two times I say hello to you Jerry
Cantrell how are you sir I'm great
well this is it this is the Vinnie Paul
trophy is uh it's given to the winner of
the Allison change celebrity fantasy
football league for charity there it is
the Vinnie Paul trophy for your late
friend great Vinnie Paul and now here is
the the champions there I am the
defending champion no more I took it
from fabs yep there you are two-time
champ right there man I am yeah oh there
you are son Ian is also a two-time champ
so join him there you go two-time champ
of this event now I guess this is a
little late for me to ask this it's not
my responsibility to engrave this is it
no I'll take care of that it comes it
comes part much that's all right we got
it yeah all right well Chris we had a
great run we were dutiful champs we did
our duty and showing off I just look at
everyday this one's for Jerry yes I'm
pretty happy with my performance I gotta
say I was expecting a little bit more
from you guys but you had a little you
had some bad luck this this year that is
a valid valid trolling that you just did
yeah like you you very subtle you yeah
you can jab has some bad luck yeah my
gosh bad luck
first to worst what are you gonna do you
know be back strong in 2020 I expect
it's try one day you're the Patriots
next day or the Bella Twins and that's
what happens that's what happens
ouch yeah well you'll bounce back let me
look at that last three run you know
like dab you know me Fabiano on you
comes right that's great okay that's
good company you know watch good come
I'm I'm very proud to be in your company
let's put
and vice versa vice versa
congratulations
so the Vinnie Paul trophy and Jerry
Cantrell will join us with the radio
audience in a second cool
his Seahawks are in the divisional round
of the playoffs the Vinnie Paul trophy
that's given to the winner of his
celebrity fantasy football league is to
his right because he took it down life
is good for lead guitarist of Alice in
Chains back here on the Rich Eisen show
Jerry Cantrell how are you brother I'm
good thanks for having me today
there is your trophy I know right there
right next to you yep and I see you've
got your phone open to the championship
game right let's do you versus James Jim
Carr
Jeff Garlin Jeff Garth go yeah okay I
was really scared about because he had
yeah Jackson he had Kittel he had Thomas
he steamrolled into the playoffs he did
and it's a PPR so Michael Thomas in the
year in which he's got a hundred and
forty four catches it's full its full
point PPR
yes he got 157 points in that game you
know oh my I just had a miracle game
with the Colts pick up on the D was 27
and Jones put me over the top now now
when you this is your championship game
you picked the Colts up defensively and
why did you pick up the Colts
defensively against Jacksonville for
that well I wanted to get I wanted to
get Denver I thought they were a solid
play but somebody somebody picked them
on who was that person who picked him up
uh I believe it was you yes and who
texted who texted me to complain you
know I'm out of it totally out of it and
it's true and who was the one who
complained about picking Denver not
being able to pick Denver up because
somebody was a a die-hard fantasy player
and was playing to the bitter end who
was that person who complained that was
me yeah and you explained that you were
a competitor and yeah and he said and
you're right I compete I should thank
you because the I had to pick up the
Colts and I got 27 points out of it so I
thank you rich Eisen that's my fantasy
paid off handsomely for somebody else
that's it but you forgot you seven that
was solid right yeah yeah
Denver got me seven yeah I got 27 yeah
yeah they got they got the defensive
touch then I got a special teams
touchdown they just they just went all
all sacks picks a [ __ ] 16 and then Jones
kind of topped it off he I was worried
when he fumbled that first that first
fumble in the game I'm like oh that's
right in the ball and then the second
half he started steamrolling so who is
your team who was the AIC but aroma of
tacoma realm of Tacoma was Russell
Wilson McCaffrey Aaron Jones
I lost Evans to injury a couple weeks
before him right picked up AJ Brown to
replace him Devante Parker Hollister who
was a nice pickup he got kind of got hot
towards you man using a Seahawk couple
seems to affect in DD Tucker of course
right now and then my bench was woods
John Brown the New Orleans D whichever
was rolling with for a while I picked up
boon you know just on the last week
because the impact was rocket it was a
Monday nighter that yet you know that
that boon was gonna start most likely
just couldn't make that play I know
you're on in the weekend it's kind of
questioning whether I should play Jones
or him I'm glad I want
Robles is rocking around on the bench
yeah what a juggernaut yeah deserve the
Vinnie Paul trophy yeah he drowned
brownie trail points on the bench Woods
had 20 points on the bench Perriman who
I picked up he has 17 points on the
bench here those guys played first so I
was like oh that's right
I just wonder what what percentage of
fantasy teams across the country won
their league who had Christian McCaffrey
because he was just so incredible this
way I'd say it's got to be probably
pretty high Jackson and Thomas Wyatt
just again just to give you an idea of
my my fantasy season you know my poker
League with all my poker buddies was won
by the team that had McCaffrey and we're
not a PPR League it's just a straight
straight up yards yes correct
but the reason why they got McCaffrey is
somebody chose Zeke right before him
because he gonna just come off the beach
from Cabo
that person asked Michael Fabiano for
advice if at Zeke or Christian McCaffrey
who should I take oh is it straight PPR
take Zeke that person who did it was me
so both champions of the league's that I
was in one because in a way I made
decisions that were thoroughly wrong
that's also some kind of shady advice
because because fab was all over
McCaffrey all year and like he's a
cowboy
[Laughter]
he's a Cowboys fan though to you so that
might have tipped the tables I guess so
but it's also my my mantra should be
from now on I'm gonna play and draft and
play guys that I enjoy watching and as
great as Zeke is I'm a Michigan guy and
why the hell am I gonna have somebody
like Zeke who would just put that stuff
and my face all the time anytime I ever
come across him Michael Thomas is just a
different story what a season that guys
haven't even though he's he is a may I
can train Scott one-and-done Jerry yeah
I cannot this the mainly the Patriots
the Saints I mean this is a big shockers
man I couldn't believe the Titans took
those guys down right and it's like wow
and then the Vikings showing up like
that I mean but they're D you know it's
been it's been solid all year then and
they they stomp those guys man yeah
let's get into the Sunday the last game
of se with you Jerry Cantrell of Alice
in Chains here on the Rich Eisen show
you nervous you know I I I picked the
Seahawks before the season started to
have about a 10 win season and people
thought I was nuts about that right they
did one better I think the team's kind
of over performed and and with the with
the slew of injuries man losing our
whole backfield and and brown and you
know it's just been a it's been a
gauntlet up guys just dropping to the
sides
yeah normally when you lose your left
tackle and you're starting running back
in your backup running on the eve of the
playoffs it's curtains but it also helps
to have Russell Wilson and if it does it
helps to have Marshawn Lynch on speed
dial yeah that was amazing that was a
move at it and I mean who saw that
coming
I didn't yeah I mean I was amazed that
they brought him up and and turban I
mean I guess the guys are in the that
they're they're in the system or
whatever but like you know how long are
they when's the last time it took a snap
marShon comes in and beasts out from
like the second quarter I know so what
is that like I mean because it gets
exciting but I'm a jet fan I mean what
is that like to have one of the most
favorite players your fandom yeah come
out of retirement yeah put on the
uniform again it's look and do what he's
done it's far pretty inspiring man you
know to me and that's it's that's such a
feel-good thing you know to me and to
have him come back especially the way
that he exited which was pretty poorly I
thought from the from the organization's
part the whole last play in the Super
Bowl not using him when we had time to
run a couple of plays and either Jam
Marsha up the hall or or do a little
little play action with Russell and him
and do that quick slant and just the way
that he left it's it's nice it's a nice
thing to have him back and and and and
and I mean you know with the defense the
defense stepping up Russell stepping up
his game and and you get you got a and
Homer homers been playing too you know
in in in in place of Carson and
imprecise and Bobby Wagner's as good as
ever yes KJ right to man is having a
great season as well yeah so we can beat
them you know we can beat a minute and I
think it could go either way i football
i nobody no idea this one yeah Chris
you're gonna do your picks right at the
end of the year yes thanks I have no
earthly idea I'm literally the shrug
emoji yeah on pretty much every one of
these games and that's the beautiful
thing Jerry Cantrell here on the Rich
Eisen show the beautiful thing about the
NFL 100 season it's totally wide open
yeah it's been totally wonderful yeah
that any of these teams why can't the
Titans go on Iran Derrick Henry is gonna
be a business decision that any
defenders are gonna have trouble doing
why can't Lamar Jackson can I you doing
what he's doing I think it's pretty
tough to I mean if you just look at it
on paper I think it's pretty tough to go
against the Niners or the or
okay more wine and Jimmy G why can't her
cousins have his time bud what you know
like you know anybody can win and I
think last week is a good example of
that sure if if for some reason right
Niners go down we get a home game right
you do if it's a win and obvious that
what it is
yes you know the Niners go down yeah and
then the Seahawks would know we only get
to Lambeau Field they're playing for the
right to host the NFC championship that
is correct or either team red goes into
the game knowing that right he have the
right with let's go into every cool NFC
Championship game and again not to get
you to fire it up crazy but there I do
believe in football God karma I do you
know karma or or that there is because
that's why sometimes I do through all of
that
choose pre-season who's gonna win the
Super Bowl based on storylines which is
the way to actually you know a
reasonable way to do it because before a
week one you're throwing darts at a
board okay pretty much you don't know
who's gonna do what sir that's why I
chose the Saints cuz it was in Miami ten
years after they won in Miami that here
they are again and I just loved the way
that they had looked coming into the
season they were a pass interference
blown call shot it's a Miss at mojo that
returned it says here I know that right
I mean so I thought that's that's why I
chose that yeah
getting Marshawn back to me just brings
back shades of the past not like Russell
well neat or Bobby Wagner of course they
could conjure it up they've been around
for a long time
Marshawn coming back like if he win if
he goes off in Lambo yep and then you
get oh we're gonna need to I'm gonna be
crap look everybody's got to go off I
mean yeah I don't think yeah the Ravens
need to have Lamar to have a Lamar type
game they can't have him missing on half
of his passes and no no and and yeah and
that sort of stuff I mean that's the
beauty of divisional playoffs it just
seems to me that there could be some
sort of mojo for any of these teams in
Seattle has wise but I agree and the
other thing I think that our team has
going for us we've had our
we haven't been so great at home which
we normally are right on the road we're
killing it you know we've we've been
really solid traveling you know I think
what we've lost one game on the way it's
seven and one in the season and
obviously one right yeah in the playoffs
right now yeah so I think the team's got
that going for whatever formula they
have to travel is is working for him and
this might be the season to get past
Green Bay I'll tell you what to season
yeah I know I guess it's the we well
you've got you've gotten past Green Bay
with uh you know the botched onside kick
they're a couple of any that's range of
games that's right you know but the San
Francisco 49ers Howard proffers say
don't want to see you and the AFC champ
they're there they're a solid team and I
would sign for that part three yeah
there's a possibility of part threes I
love this conversation again
Allison change lead guitarist Jerry
Cantrell here there's a possibility for
an NFC Championship game rematch for a
third like a part three yeah with
Seattle in San Francisco that's right
there's a possibility of an NFC champion
game rematch Green Bay versus Vikings
part three yeah there is a possibility
in the AFC of a Texans Titans part three
where the first one you know I know this
is not the sexiest idea with all due
respect nicely done
we say that if you say all with all due
respect gives you full license to be
thoroughly disrespectful laughter of
course the first Texans Titans game was
the one in Tennessee that the Texans won
and then the second one was the one
where the Texans took a knee on the rest
of the regular season to save up much of
their starters and the Titans destroyed
the Texans in week 17 to get into the
playoffs right that's a possibility of a
rematch right there that's all really
exciting and you could get a Ravens
Kansas City part - mm-hmm you can get a
Ravens I guess that's a that's a have
the tech I don't know if the Titans or
the the Chiefs have played one another
in a way - well the tot yeah but Titans
beat the Chiefs earlier this year
remember that one we're Tannehill one at
the very end of that game and it looked
like
the Chiefs we're gonna win it it's fun
yeah were you watching a game home I'm
gonna be watching at home we got a
couple friends coming over but Jackalope
and all the paintings Jackalope got the
cats yeah it's like my first time in the
playoff sometimes you can I got rattled
they got my little demonic gargoyles
were rolling around the table yeah
creepy it's awesome but it's creepy
they were basically parked out on the
table in front of Hanson though before
calling this man's house creepy no I
mean I loved it obviously you called my
house set it up with the all with all
due respect you just went in just for my
rock-and-roller I'm a little bit of a
creep so what goes with the job title I
always love doing this for fans with
fans when I announced that you were on
the show yeah I got a tweet from a
gentleman named Jeff Mackey okay he says
can you ask Jerry Cantrell when Alison
change is going to play sea of sorrow
live again it's been over 25 years since
they played it live one of their best
songs ever he is correct and I can't
answer that question it's gonna be we're
kind of taking this year off so -
probably be another year but so it's for
the possibility how do you choose what
you play live or why you don't play
something live for a long time I mean
there's like you know there's there's
there's a there's a batch of tunes that
you kind of got a play for the majority
of the people that want to see a play
and there's and then there's a batch of
tunes which you can kind of swap in and
out
we generally pick a few on each leg to
kind of work in and that one hasn't been
in one of those like kind of rotational
kind of things but I'll put in a boat
for you I don't like only one vote I
know I know
yeah but I'm just curious how are you
aware of songs that you haven't played
in a while early okay absolutely I just
did I just did a couple of solo shows on
December 6th and 7th that
the Pico Union project a little church
that was really cool and and not only
did I my setlist what I not only did I
play songs that I haven't played in like
nineteen years off my two solo records I
also took a lot of old Alice stuff that
we never play either and played some of
that too so it's kind of fun kind of
rolling through that so when we get back
together all I've gone through some of
that stuff to bring back to the band
like hey why don't we play this one sure
no okay yeah and we got a caller here -
Tom and or yeah let's let's take Tom's
phone call we were on the law Rich Eisen
Tom and Jerry and Trulia Tom and Jerry
very good Gary Fulton Cantrell how are
ya
Jerry Fulton Cantrell junior pal band
well yeah yeah I don't know if you
remember me we worked together on the
tripod album over at over in Seattle at
studio X the self-titled record that's
right how you doing good man how are you
I'm good you're looking good man I'm
looking at you on TV right now
thanks as my as my wig straight how was
Jerry to work with Tom I was talking and
that was one of the most fun projects I
ever worked on my life was six months
for the best time I ever had
how was Sam you keep in touch with him
no I haven't seen Sammy and a long time
actually I'm in I'm in the restaurant
business now I'm a nice okay about out
of the music business about 15 years ago
unfortunates were smart man smart I'm it
that desperately but you know hey what
can you do that's yeah it's fun what hey
men talk to you again as you know yeah I
mean we got the sea hags against the
Packers now I'll do you one better see
donkeys come on Tom appreciate the call
thank you right there boy you're getting
disrespected by Chris calling your house
creepy don't go on your team sea hags
I'm just having fun at times a key
chicken by the way that is just for me
personally again I'm not a musician a
worldwide famous musician like you Jerry
but when I meet people and they say you
don't remember me do you
or do me that
that just strikes fear in the hearts it
does it does no because if I say yeah so
but you went with another person that
you knew and to draw it out well that's
a pro to be able to see that did you
draw it out to energy and then and then
you remembered Sam yeah well I think
he's like a second assistant to sam sam
was like the engineers yeah yeah yeah
and that was that was at the now-defunct
oh it was bad animals and became studio
acts of which was also where we recorded
our last record Rainier fog and that was
pretty much the last big record before
it closed last year 25 years ago - yes
impressive yeah yeah look at your memory
yes well I've got some holes but
coincidentally an odd fact like the old
era Alice in the new era Alice both of
our third records were recorded at that
studio fantastic Congrats and getting
your trophy back yeah man I'm really
puttin that thing we're gonna go I'm
gonna put it right up next to my
Seahawks trophy from the Super Bowl
where I got about 30 of the players also
that signed it very nice and I'm gonna
take the proceeds of the charity auction
we do every year and I'm gonna donate it
to music cares so music cares yeah which
is again it's for musicians who are down
on their luck a little bit needs help
right yeah it deals with issues of
alcoholism and other other other other
other fantastic well enjoy putting that
in your house now well and I'm sure it
will make the house less creepy look I
take it as a compliment so much I love
the artwork at Jerry's house as long as
long as I'm a half a creep I'm not a
whole little creepy
next year I'm gonna comment on be more
focused so uh cuz I want that trophy
back Jerry Cantrell on Twitter and
Instagram good to see to have a great
one with your Seahawk oh thanks for
havin any time and thanks for promoting
oh you bet absolutely Jerry Cantrell
here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app